hier sprechen wir mit christian der
matzdorf ist professor für kriminalistik
und kriminaltechnik schön dass sie bei
uns sind hermsdorf so viele fragen zu
diesem grausamen fall vor allem die
frage wie konnte es dazu kommen der
täter bereits vorbestraft war in einem
programm für wiedereingliederung da
sollte man auch an dem er ist die ganze
zeit unter beobachtung und den behörden
müsse auffallen wenn der sich im
internet mit einem jungen mädchen
verabredet
ja die wahrheit ist und das ist etwas
was vielleicht gar nicht so bewusst sein
hier steht dass es keine lückenlose rund
um die uhr haut geben kann wir haben
hunderte wenn nicht tausende von
sexualstraftätern in der bundesrepublik
die beobachtet werden müssten
theoretisch rund um die uhr wir haben
noch andere aufgaben die polizei
wahrnehmen muss beispielsweise
terroristische gefährder ähnliches es
gibt keine lückenlose überwachung rund
um die uhr dass der erste wichtige
fakten dieser angelegenheit das weiteren
natürlich unverständlich dass ein mensch
der schon schwere straftaten begangen
hat hier gerade in diesem bereich
sexualdelikten an kindern dann die
möglichkeit hat taten zu begehen das
liegt daran dass die justiz eine
entscheidung treffen muss das gutachten
eine entscheidung treffen und dass die
justiz am ende dann auch sein treffen
muss ob die freiheitsrechte diesen
menschen höher einzuschätzen das
gefährdungsrisiko diese entscheidung
sind oftmals sehr umstritten und auch
für mich häufig nicht nachvollziehbar
wenn man ein risiko für die
allgemeinheit über die freiheitsrechte
den einzelnen betroffenen straftäter
gestellt also aline ist offenbar opfer
einer fehleinschätzung eines gutachtens
geworden
man müsste jetzt den gesamten prozess
betrachten dazu braucht man ein
intensives aktenstudium das kann nicht
von hier aus nicht leisten darüber kann
davon ausgehen dass ein mensch der in
haft gesessen hat ob es jetzt strafhaft
da bisschen maßregelvollzug gezogen hat
sei dahingestellt dass der an einem
bestimmten punkt entweder im rahmen des
urteils wenn zb keine
sicherungsverwahrung angeordnet worden
ist oder im nachhinein dann durch eine
gutachterliche aussage eine prognose
bekommen hat die aussagt das risiko ist
vorhanden aber nicht so groß dass man
ihn nicht in freiheit entlassen kann
dass man ein risiko gesehen hat sieht
man daran dass die polizei mit dem fall
befasst war ich hätte eigentlich irgend
eine überprüfung der aktivitäten im
internet eines solchen mannes statt oder
kann der im internet egal was er vorher
begangen hat zunächst einmal tun und
lassen was aber
wir haben in der bundesrepublik ein
ich würde es sagen umgangssprachlich
eine heilige kuh das ist der datenschutz
oder sind die freiheitsrechte der person
das recht auf informelle
selbstbestimmung ein sich eine gute
sache die hier gar nicht bestritten
werden soll tatsache ist aber dass das
die möglichkeiten ermittlungsbehörden
ganzheitlich beschneidet und
beispielsweise eine überwachung auch der
internet aktivitäten einer person so gar
nicht möglich macht bzw auch technisch
gar nicht möglich ist wann hast du
schnell bei dem alten satz den auch der
altkanzler gerhard schröder mal gesagt
hat wegsperren für immer jetzt einmal
ganz sachlich gefragt lassen sich solche
männer solche sexualstraftäter
tatsächlich nach abgesessener haftstrafe
wieder eingliedern also vor kann so
etwas funktionieren dass sie ganz normal
unter uns leben oder eben nicht
straffällig werden
menschen mit einer sexuellen
orientierung die nicht therapierbar ist
die nur beispielsweise segment
medikamentöse ge haben dann griff
bekommen werden kann können nicht
geheilt werden können noch nicht als
geheilt entlassen werden es kommt sehr
stark auf die tat anders kommt darauf an
ob es sich um einen menschen mit einer
fehl- orientierung handelt oder ob
andere hintergründe vorliegen
grundsätzlich muss man sagen dass immer
ein risiko besteht und dieses risiko
individuell einzuschätzen ist ein
bisschen wie in einer glaskugel lesen
das kann man nie vorhersehen man sollte
allerdings überlegen ob man nicht
tatsächlich die den schutz der
gesellschaft vor den freiheitsrechten
der person in der abwägung geben
zugunsten der gesellschaft und weniger
im einzelfall dann für das risiko dass
ein straftäter weiter gestrafft hat
beginnt hier ausspricht das ist das was
mich beschäftigt
professor christian maria veen
herzlichen danke ihnen für das gespräch
die lufthansa wird immer mehr zum boden
hansa und zur streik hansa vor allen
dingen und das mitten in den
sommerurlaub wochen sie werden dass
möglicherweise auch schon gespürt haben
die pilotengewerkschaft cockpit die hat
jetzt am wochenende per urabstimmung
beschlossen ja auch wir werden streiken
darüber müssen wir sprechen mit matthias
beyer dem presse vorstand der
vereinigung cockpit also der der dort
bei bei den piloten auskunft gibt
aktuell große herzlich
schön und wissen sie wen sie damit
treffen mit ihren angekündigten streiks
wir haben gar keinen streik angekündigt
wir haben eine urabstimmung durchgeführt
und diese urabstimmung ist keine
kampfmaßnahme eine urabstimmung dient
der interne willensbildung im verband
und hier hat sich das ergeben dass die
piloten der meinung der
konzerntarifkommission folgen dass die
verhandlung hier mit dem entsprechenden
forderungen weitergeführt werden soll
beziehungsweise die gespräche allerdings
sind die verhandlungen gegenwärtig ja
gescheitert beide parteien aber gesagt
sie sagen gesprächsbereit und jetzt eine
urabstimmung ist nicht das ende aller
möglichkeiten nein ganz im gegenteil wir
werden mit gesprächen weitermachen aber
jetzt noch mal klartext also für alle
urlauber für alle die flüge gebucht
haben müssen sie sich jetzt auf streiks
von ihnen einstellen oder gibt es ein
warnung von ihnen
weder das eine noch das andere kann ich
ihnen absolut sagen weil im moment hängt
jetzt davon ab wie diese gespräche
verlaufen und ich bin aber sehr
optimistisch dass das klappen wird es
ist ja auch nicht sind uns hier keiner
gewerkschaft zu streiken sondern es ist
hin und weg angemessene tarifverträge
auszuhandeln und in dem szenario
befinden wir uns jetzt
gegenwärtig gibt es keinen antrag auf
arbeitskampfmaßnahmen wie gesagt die
beiden parteien haben erklärt sie
möchten weiter miteinander reden und ich
glaube auch dass wieder ein ergebnis
erzielt werden er drücke natürlich alle
die daumen dennoch sie sehen die langen
schlangen eben gerade an den deutschen
flughäfen es ist für uns jetzt mitten
zur urlaubszeit erfasst ja schon ein
bild des alltags ein absolutes frust
bild geworden was denken sie denn wenn
sie an die urlauber da stehen wir kommen
alle aus zwei jahren pandemie wir haben
alle ein dickes brett im herbst und
winter vor uns wo wir nicht wissen was
uns droht und jetzt wir hoffen alle da
sind wir uns hier drei einig dass es
nicht soweit kommt aber jetzt wenn man
es so zuspitzen lassen dass er streit
zumindest im raum steht dass das ein
guter zeitpunkt
erhielt treffen ja sehr viele sachen
aufeinander zu einen muss man
dass die tarifverträge seit dem ersten
juli offen sind und man muss auch
verstehen dass die tarifparteien seit
juni miteinander über diese
vergütungsstrukturen hier reden sie sind
nicht zueinander gekommen ich habe
natürlich sehr grosses verständnis für
die befürchtung der passagiere niemand
ist gerne opfer einer
arbeitskampfmaßnahme und aber auch
niemand nimmt gerne an einer
arbeitskampfmaßnahme teil das heißt also
hier muss man einfach sagen gut lassen
die beiden parteien miteinander reden
dafür sie möchten gerne versuchen
aufeinander zu zu kommen und wenn das
alles so klappt dann haben wir nichts zu
befürchten aber eine garantie kann ihnen
leider niemand wählen einmal noch mal
karten auf den tisch was verdienten im
moment ein pilot eigentlich vor allen
dingen auch gemessen an denen die da an
der schlange stehen an den flughäfen
deutlich mehr oder
ja das kann ich gar nicht genau
einschätzen wo die bei wem die da stehen
in der schlange es gibt der ganze reihe
von fluggesellschaften
das ist eine große bandbreite also ich
nehme die plakative zahl dieser gerne
mal kursiert der das erreichen sie nur
wenn sie wirklich sehr sehr lange bei
einer firma bleiben und dort auch weit
aufgestiegen sind möglicherweise sogar
trainings kapitän jack kapitän geworden
sind ist aber ein sehr langer prozess
und die meisten die stolz ich mit
deutlich weniger und
jetzt 250.000 brutto im jahr das ist die
zeit die sie jetzt ansprechen wenn man
lange dabei ist lange schon fliegt dann
kann es zu diesem gehalt gehen ist
hamburg das kann dazu kommen ja das ist
richtig sie fangen aber mit deutlich
weniger anlagen
das ist überall so ganz genau dann
entwickelt sich das es gibt manchmal
deckel in den tarifverträgen dann kommen
sie nicht weiter lang stoßen selber
bleibt auch für sehr lange zeit in
diesen decke hängen also da lässt sich
das nicht an
dann müssen wir schon eine zahl sagen wo
ist denn die zahl für die sie jetzt
kämpfen wo sie sagen das ist nicht
gerecht gegenüber piloten und dafür
nehmen wir unter allen eventualitäten
wenn die gespräche steigern auch in kauf
dass die menschen die wir gehen den
bildern sehen dann noch länger warten
dass sie noch mehr frust habe ist
vielleicht gar nicht in urlaub schaffen
und danach ellenlange e mails schreiben
weil sie ihr geld nicht wieder bekommen
wo ist die zahl wohl für sie sagen
unsere schmerzgrenze ist erreicht da
reden wir nicht über 250.000 euro brutto
ja wir verhandeln ja keine absoluten
gehälter sondern wir verhandeln jetzt
eine steigerungsrate beziehungsweise das
war das was die konzerntarifkommission
vorgeschlagen hat und die rechtfertigt
sich dadurch dass wir natürlich eine
lange zeit haben in dem es überhaupt
keine oder nur geringe steigerung
gegeben hat und wie in jeder
gehaltsverhandlung auch das kennen sie
und ich und jeder andere auch hier der
im angestelltenverhältnis sich befindet
der weißen muss um sein gehalt natürlich
verhandelt gewerkschaften verhandeln
sich nicht nach unten soll
wo es nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu
arbeiten gab für die blüten und piloten
in der pandemie konnte nicht so viel
abgehoben werden wir vorher
sie ziehen jetzt haben auch die
vergangenen zwei jahre wenn sie jetzt
ganz speziell bei der lufthansa bleiben
dort hat die lufthansa im dezember
angefangen zurückzuzahlen und hat dann
auch im juli ganz überraschend gewinne
gemacht das ist aber jetzt nicht
entscheidend entscheidend ist dass die
arbeit die sie jetzt machen im nächsten
jahr die gleiche ist aber im
wahrscheinlich acht prozent weniger wert
ist und ich glaube da ist es ganz
natürlich dass wir gehälter nach oben
verhandeln wollen das macht ja versucht
ihr praktisch jeder das ein bisschen
besser gestellt ist sagt matthias beyer
von der pilotenvereinigung cockpit der
einen streik hier leider bei bild live
nicht ausschließen möchte das hätten wir
uns so sehr gewünscht die anti streik
daran hier bei
bild.de urlaub nicht an gerd beyer
dennoch danke schön herr wir drücken uns
die neuen
ländern das nimmt ja immer absurdere
formen aber jetzt stehen sogar
wissenschaftler bei ard und zdf dagegen
auf sie vor den schluss mit dieser
gender sprache dort bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen im tv
das weitaus weniger riskant für deutsche
steuerzahler innen steuergelder das hat
jetzt auch von ihnen gewartet
ein
saarländer das klappt bei dem einen
schon ganz gut oder wie hier bei
bundeskanzler olaf scholz weniger gut
vor jedem und für jeden jeder die
bürgerinnen und bürger eine entlastung
bekommen finde aber dass wir schon sehr
sehr viele bürgerinnen bürger geimpft
haben generell spaltet die gender
debatte die gesellschaft die befürworter
sagen gendern sei ein muss und nur so
fühlen sich alle in der gesellschaft
akzeptiert und auch der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk setzt auf
sendern die meisten anderen in unserer
gesellschaft finden es einfach nur
quatsch genau wie auch mehr als 100
linguisten und organisationen jetzt
einen aufruf gegen die gender sprach im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
unterzeichnet haben sie fordern damit
ein ende des gender wahnsinns
darüber müssen wir sprechen und zwar mit
unserem b politik reporter sebastian
geisler hier bei uns im studio schön es
hier ist das getrieben wird was ist da
los da sind jetzt also mittlerweile
schon über 90 wissenschaftler die
aufstehen gegen das gender im
öffentlich-rechtlichen aus einer reihe
von gründen sie sagen das lässt sich aus
der sprache heraus aus der grammatik
nicht begründen diese kunstsprache von
der sie da auch sprechen sie sagen es
spricht eigentlich entspricht nicht dem
programm auftrag der
öffentlich-rechtlichen uns eine gender
sprache an zu erziehen und sie sagen
sogar dass die öffentlich-rechtlichen
wenn sie selbst über das phänomen
gendern berichten nicht neutral
berichten sondern sich dann teilweise
einzelne aktivisten ranholen auch aus
der wissenschaft die so tun als gäbe es
da so in wissenschaftlichen konsens
dafür sie sagen aber nein diesen
wissenschaftlichen konsens gibt es eben
nicht und deswegen machen sie jetzt auch
diesen aufruf und sagen nein wir
wissenschaftler sind auch da das ist
hoch kontrovers es gibt keinen sozusagen
pro ländern in der wissenschaft darum
geht es diesen leuten kann man das rad
aber wieder zurückdrehen also das ist ja
jetzt die frage anhand dieses aufrufes
wird diese aufrufe erfolg haben wird der
widerstand erfolg haben oder wird eben
einfach weiter geändert und das ist
nicht mehr aufzuhalten als ich glaube
einerseits da formiert sich so ein
bisschen war es dann gibt's jetzt
widerstand da sind leute auch aufgewacht
und sagen na ja ein wenig jetzt mal
dagegen halten und sagen wir lehnen das
aber ab dann setzten sich eben die
gender aktivisten damit durch zum einen
zum anderen habe ich aber mal angefragt
bei ard und zdf wie sieht es dann aus
jetzt gibt's diesen aufruf wollt ihr
vielleicht jetzt aufhören mit dem gender
dieses zum beispiel vom zdf nein wir
stellen es unseren moderatoren weiterhin
frei zu gendern also offensichtlich ist
es dann egal auch dass rund 80 prozent
der gebührenzahler auch sagen wir
möchten das eigentlich so nicht haben in
unseren sendungen jetzt bereits
irgendeine reaktion seitens der
wissenschaft sind weitere aktionen
aufrufe geplant um auf dieses thema
weiter aufmerksam zu machen oder ist es
jetzt eine debatte die im sande verläuft
wir machen so weiter wir hören euch
nicht fertig aus ist ja ja ja der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk braucht
ja auch sozusagen seine legitimation
dass er auch seine gebühren von uns
allen einzieht wenn natürlich 80 prozent
der menschen eigentlich gegen das zu
ändern sind ist schon die frage wie kann
das eigentlich sein es schließe sich
jetzt immer mehr wissenschaftler diesem
aufruf an mal sehen dass gewinnt jetzt
gerade ein bisschen an fatih ganz so nah
so fern vielleicht wird es ja
tatsächlich wird dann kann unser bild
reporter bildpolitik reporter sebastian
geist oder zum ländern im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen ard und zdf danke
die große streit um die letzten
deutschen atomkraftwerke dieser streit
ist das politische thema dieser woche
den die regierung sie zerlegt sich
gegenseitig in diesem atomkraft streit
und sie hat noch mal richtig öl ins
feuer gegossen in diesem streit ricarda
lang die grünen-chefin sie schließt ein
wiedereinstieg in die atomkraft jetzt
nämlich kategorisch aus rumms und das
während der andere teil der regierung
gerade diesen wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft vorbereitet christian lindner
der fdp chef und bundesfinanzminister er
hat ja das gesagt zur möglichen
verlängerung der akw-laufzeiten vieles
spricht dafür die sicheren und
klimafreundlichen kernkraftwerke nicht
abzuschalten sondern nötigenfalls bis 20
24 zu nutzen und jetzt eben die antwort
der grünen co chefin ricarda lang das
hat sie am abend im zdf gesagt
das was die anbieter will ist nichts
anderes als der wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft und das wird es mit uns auf
jeden fall nicht geben ich finde
manchmal dass wir eine etwas unernst
heftigkeit in dieser debatte haben dafür
dass immer noch über eine
hochrisikotechnologie sprechen viele
menschen machen sich sorgen mit blick
auf winter und im blick auf den herbst
was die gas versorgen was die
energieversorgung angeht und gerade weil
diese sorgen da sind sind hier ist
glaube ich verpflichtet den menschen
antworten zu geben die auch tatsächlich
zum problemen passen also das zu tun was
wirklich hilft aber das lassen was
eigentlich nicht möglich hilft ein
klares nein
chorisches nein der grünen co chefin
ricarda lang zum wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft und das in dieser energiekrise
im jahr 2022 zu meist gesuchten betrüger
der welt der ist auf freiem fuß in
moskau unterwegs unglaubliche geschichte
es geht um jan marsalek wirecard
milliardenbetrüger bka europol alle sind
hinter ihm her nicht ganz alle denn
putin der lässt ihn bei sich im land
ganz wunderbar leben und lieben der
blick aufs handy die haare kurz
geschoren die jacke rot eine auffällige
farbe für jemanden der eigentlich
unerkannt bleiben will jan most wanted
marsalek gesichtet in moskau es ist der
beweis deutschlands größter
wirtschaftsbetrüger ist im reich von
kreml tür an putin es ist die nächste
große enthüllung in der akte wirecard
der größte finanzskandal seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg und an der spitze der
österreicher jan marsalek rückblick das
zahlungsverkehrs
dienstleistungsunternehmen gilt jahre
lang als deutsches vorzeigeunternehmen
wird hofiert von spitzenpolitikern
darunter auch von der damaligen
kanzlerin angela merkel doch die
ereignisse des 19 juni 2020 stellen das
unternehmen und die deutsche finanzwelt
auf den kommen 1,9 milliarden euro
fehlen in der kasse des dax-unternehmens
verträge geschäft der weltweite konto
bewegungen alles erfunden die wirecard
aktie stürzt ab die gläubiger werden um
3,1 milliarden geschädigt und jan
marsalek flüchtet seine flucht führt von
vöslauer in österreich über minz bis hin
nach moskau auf seiner flucht wechselt
der milliarden-betrüger mehrere male
seine identität seitdem lebt jan maser
lag das luxusleben im land des kreml des
kunden genießt feinstes essen im
fischrestaurant marie fährt ein fettes
auto und lebt in einer luxusvilla nur 20
kilometer vom kreml entfernt dazu steht
deutschlands meistgesuchter betrüger
unter ständigen schutz von putins
geheimdienst seit juni 2021 soll massa
lag sogar russischer staatsbürger seien
seine neue identität
germanische raum unfassbar wie bild im
april exklusiv berichtete erfährt der
bundesnachrichtendienst bereits im
frühjahr 21 wo sich jan marsalek aufhält
und informiert das kanzleramt darüber
außerdem bietet der russische
geheimdienst der behörde sogar an jan
maser lag zu verhören die reaktion ist
ganz leichtes stille keine reaktion die
enthüllung über janas alex genauen
flucht dort kommt kurz vor merkels
zeugenaussage in wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss wären maß alex
aussagen zum problem für die kanzlerin
geworden nach bild informationen hat der
bundesnachrichtendienst nach diesen
aufnahmen bereits erneut eine
auslieferung von jan marsalek beantragt
doch seit putins krieg in der ukraine
gilt diese als unwahrscheinlich und das
ist nicht weniger als der nächste
skandal im britischen königshaus geld
das stinkt aber ganz gewaltig prinz
charles hat sich es in die tasche
gesteckt für seine
wohltätigkeitsorganisation
1,19 millionen euro eine spende und zwar
von verwandten von halbbrüdern von osama
bin laden eine million spende an das
britische königshaus von verwandten von
ihm dem einstigen ober terrorführer des
mannes der für die gräueltaten des 11
septembers so wesentlich verantwortlich
ist im jahr 2013 soll sich prinz charles
mit einem der brüder bagger bin laden in
seiner londoner residenz getroffen haben
das geld hat der könig von england in
spe angenommen obwohl seine berater ihn
aufgefordert haben genau das nicht zu
tun also ein neuer skandal diesmal geht
es um gewaltig stinken das geld dort im
britischen königshaus und es geht
offenbar immer noch grausamer im ukraine
krieg schauen sie auf diese brutalen
setzte der russischen regierung in
diesem fall der russischen botschaft in
großbritannien sie schreibt asaf
militanten verdienen die hinrichtung
aber nicht durch ein
erschießungskommando sondern durch
erhängen denn sie sind keine echten
soldaten sie verdienen einen erniedrigen
den tod dass die worte der russischen
botschaft in großbritannien das ist eine
neue dimension noch mal eine neue
grausame dimension in diesem ukraine
krieg denn es ist nichts anderes als die
aufforderung einer offiziellen stelle
der russischen regierung ein
kriegsverbrechen zu begehen
kriegsverbrechen an den asus kämpfern
das sind auch die männer die wochenlang
in diesem maß auf stahlwerk ihr in mario
pohl im osten der ukraine gekämpft haben
dort wo der krieg also so besonders
erbarmungslos und brutal war diese
überlebenden kämpfer aus dem stahlwerk
die wollen die russen also nun so brutal
ermorden lassen dazu ruft die russische
botschaft in großbritannien auf und
dabei sind unsere reporter weiter tag
für tag in der ukraine unterwegs in
diesem krieg um ihnen das ganze bild
dieses krieges zu zeigen unser bild
kriegsreporter björn stritzel ist
derzeit mit mörser einheiten unterwegs
mit mörser einheiten der ukraine
jetzt schlagen sie zurück mörser raketen
abgefeuert auf russische stellungen sie
donnern richtung ist der vielleicht
wichtigsten stadt für den russischen
nation
petja und sein team versuchen die
versorgungslinien der russischen
invasoren zu stören und erste erfolge
deuten sich an nachdem die russischen
munitionsdepot zerstört haben gibt es
weniger raketeneinschläge
bild-reporter bion strietzel ist an der
front begleitet das ukrainische mehrzad
ihn im kampfeinsatz
dann kommt die durchsage per funk
es geht los mit ja und sein team
springen auflaufen zu ihren fahrzeugen
nach einigen kilometern fahrt in
richtung der russischen stellungen
erreichen sie eine lichtung das gebüsch
bietet sich schutz gegen russische
drohen wir sind ja in der ost ukraine an
der front nahe bei ysl und begleitet
hier gerade zwei moerser teams die mit
ihren 82 mm lösung gleich versuchen
werden die russische stellung unter
vorjahr zulegen das ist ein wenig
riskant für diese teams immer deshalb
weil sie relativ nah heranfahren müssen
danach sich schnell wieder zurückziehen
um eben dem russischen gegen voll zu
entkommen momentan warten die beiden
teams noch darauf dass die ziele
bestätigt werden ihrem börse sind jetzt
in position gebracht und dann geht es
auch gleich los blitzschnell bauen die
soll darf nur zwei moerser aufliegen die
granaten bereit
dann die nächste durchsage ein
ukrainischer kommandant gibt die
zielkoordinaten durch
[Musik]
während das letzte chance noch in der
luft ist warum die männer eilig zusammen
verladen die moerser in die fahrzeuge
und rasen wieder weg bevor der russische
gegenschlag kopf
und bereiten sich dann auf den nächsten
angriff vor
spektakulärer einbruch heute nacht in
leipzig mitten in leipzig mitten in der
city in das juweliergeschäft brinkmann
und lagen dass die bilder aus der nacht
von dort wie gesagt mitten aus der stadt
viertel vor drei ist das passiert hatte
rannten die einbrecher mit einem auto
dort gegen des sicherheits rolltor dort
eine eingangstür wumms rein und sind
dann die polizei sagt mit einem
hammerähnlichen gegenstand rhein haben
da noch die eingangstür zusammen
geschlagen die scheiben zerstört preetz
aber natürlich wenige minuten nach dem
überfall am tatort aber bisher keine
spur und das besondere kommt jetzt an
diesem einbruch mit dem auto sie hören
hier noch die alarmanlage alles schon
passiert genau vor einem jahr nämlich
april 20 21 von da stammen diese bilder
offenbar organisierte kriminalität
damals eine bande auch mit dem autor ein
in dieses juweliergeschäft und damals
fette beute gemacht nämlich in
millionenhöhe schmuck und luxusuhren
ausgeräumten teil davon konnte später in
polen sichergestellt werden aber bei
weitem nicht alles auch damals die täter
entkommen also innerhalb so kurzer zeit
der zweite heftige einbruch dort mitten
in der leipziger city in dieses genau
dieses juweliergeschäft also reportage
rum nußbaum ist vor ort mit ihm darüber
sprechen kann das eigentlich zufall sein
jerome oder finden die behörden die
polizei da jetzt schon da einige
parallelen zwischen dem vorfall aus dem
letzten jahr und dem einbruch jetzt bei
der polizei ist es wirklich so dass er
gerade die ermittlungen anlaufen die
können schon sagen dass es wohl keinen
zusammenhang mit dem einbruch vom
letzten jahr gab zumindest nicht zu
diesen tätern denn ihr habt es ja gesagt
für tatverdächtige konnten damals in
polen festgenommen werden nur drei tage
nach dem einbruch und die sitzen wohl
auch immer noch in haft allerdings ist
die kommunikation mit den behörden in
print und bisschen schwierig sagt um uns
die polizei in leipzig und deswegen man
spricht man vermutet es zumindest zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt von trittbrettfahrern
das geschäft liegt natürlich optimal
mitten in der city von leipzig nach
245 ist dann natürlich auch nichts los
man sieht hier der kameramann könnte ein
bisschen schwenken darf man eigentlich
nur ein bisschen anlauf nehmen muss von
der linken seite mit dem auto direkt in
das rolltor so wie beim letzten mal
entstehen zwar direkt vor mir ein paar
bänke die das abhalten könnten aber da
ist noch genug anlauf um das zu kriegen
es gibt noch einen weiteren juwelier
direkt um die ecke der ist aber in einer
passage gelegen da kommst du mit so
einem rahmen auto nicht ran und könnte
es nicht diesen versuch unternehmen das
rolltor zu öffnen inzwischen gibt es
auch erste hinweise zu den tätern es
sollen wieder wie im letzten jahr drei
täter gewesen sein dunkel gekleidet nach
zeugenaussagen und auch nach auswertung
der bewachung kamera dunkel gekleidet
dunkle hautfarbe wohl einer der täter
trug einen hut mit krempe und das tat
auto soll in diesem jahr wieder
dunkelblau gewesen seien wie im letzten
jahr wohl ein vw passat und der soll
auch wie im letzten jahr diese
parallelen sind unglaublich zwei tage
zuvor im süden kommt es nicht gestohlen
worden sein zumindest ist das jetzt der
erste verdacht und danach wird gefahndet
also doch etliche parallelen zwischen
diesen beiden taten diesen beiden
einbrüchen innerhalb eines guten jahres
strom jetzt ist das eine absolute
albtraum jahr für den eigentümer dieses
juweliergeschäftes dort mitten in der
stadt was hörst du von dort aus dem
geschäft und vor allen dingen auch wie
wird man sich das schützen also plant
man jetzt möglicherweise der poller
aufzustellen
direkt vor dem geschäft
wir haben kurz denen der boutique
besitzer so heißt es sehr der store
manager sozusagen gesprochen er ist
natürlich fertig mit den nerven wieder
dieser arbeit allerdings dass die gute
nachricht es wurde nichts gestohlen im
letzten jahr wieder wurde wurde über
eine million euro schaden angerichtet
stehlschaden und diesmal ist wohl nichts
verschwunden er hat offensichtlich der
sicherheitsvorkehrungen hoffen und hatte
auch vor direkt vor dem ladeneingang
einen poller errichten zu lassen aber es
ist nur ein fußgängerzone da hat wohl
nach seinen angaben die stadt gesagt
nein das können wir nicht machen das
wird zu einem hindernis und könnte hier
fußgänger gefährden zu einem
stolperstein werden aber vielleicht
jetzt nach diesem zweiten einbruch
innerhalb von gut einem jahr wäre das
eine überlegung um das zu sichern schaue
- warum vielen herzlichen dank deine
informationen aus leipzig dort zum
zweiten mal in ein juweliergeschäft
eingebrochen im auto rein der schmuck
ist raus danke
[Musik]